have you ever met a person who was a
great reader when they were young who
was not successful you never never it's
incredibly hard to get people to take
bold bets and you need to encourage that
I complain a lot when I was young
because I think Bill Gates took odd
opportunities for the Microsoft and
Steve Jobs all these guys there's no job
there's no great big stuff left for us
wanna be happy
build a life not just a business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel
was created to help you overcome the
number one challenge that is holding you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you know
there's something greater inside you as
well you are a genius so today let's
live your best belief life and learn the
everyday habits that billionaires apply
to their lives
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one be a great reader with Oprah Winfrey
and I would say reading is the strongest
signal for success in the future that
I've ever seen it is the strongest
strongest strongest I got my first job
in radio when I was 16 years old because
I've been in broadcasting since I was 16
years old but my first job I got because
I was a great reader when you are a
great reader you can articulate and
speak and command the English language
in ways that other people cannot and
people think you're a lot smarter than
you are lots of times
because you're great reader have you
ever met a person who was a great reader
when they were young who was not
successful you never never it is the
absolute best foundation ever in life
how about number two take bold bets with
Jeff Bezos my job one of my jobs as the
leader of Amazon
is to encourage people to be bold and
people love to focus on things that
aren't yet working and that's good it's
human nature that kind of divine
discontent can be very helpful but you
really you know it's incredibly hard to
get people to take bold bets and you
need to encourage that and if you're
gonna take bold bets
they're gonna be experiments and if
they're experiments you don't know ahead
of time though they're gonna work
experiments are by their very nature
prone to failure but big success is a
few big successes compensate for dozens
and dozens of things that didn't work so
you know bold bets AWS Kindle Amazon
Prime our 3rd party seller business all
of those things are examples of bold
bets that that that did work and they
pay for a lot of experiments I've made
billions of dollars of failures at
amazon.com literally billions of dollars
of failures and you know you might
remember pets calm or Cosmo or you know
give myself a root canal with no
anesthesia very easily none of those
things are fun but but they also they
don't matter what really matters is
companies that don't continue to
experiment companies that don't embrace
failure they eventually get in the
desperate position where they only thing
they can do is we could kind of Hail
Mary bet at the very end of their
corporate existence where as companies
that are you know making bets all along
even you know big bets but not bet the
company bets I don't I don't believe in
bet the company bets that's when you're
desperate that's that's the last thing
you can do also if you want to have more
confidence check my 254 series they're
free the links joint are in the
description below they think that
success is supposed to happen like that
the stress primarily comes from not
taking action it's so difficult
to be a small business owner in China it
took me five months to more than $500
habit number three see challenges as
opportunities with Jack Ma let's world
today's of full of challenges and
opportunities 2,000 years ago full of
challenges and opportunities and I'm
sure 2,000 years later
full of challenges and opportunities
there's always it depends on how you
look at somebody look at this challenge
as opportunity young people always say
there's no opportunity I complain a lot
when I was young because I think Bill
Gates took odd opportunities for the
Microsoft Steve Jobs all these guys
there's no job there's no great big
stuff left for us but I think
opportunity always lies in the
challenges always lies in the complaints
if you can solve the challenge you have
there you will be successful
the big challenge you solve the big
problem of the the big opportunity you
have have it number four take care of
your mind and body with warren buffett
seventy years ago I was in high school
almost a third as long as the country
has been around
and when I was in high school I really
only had two things on my mind
girls and cars and and I wasn't doing
very well with girls so we'll talk about
cars but let's just imagine that when we
finish I'm gonna let each one of you
pick out the car of your choice sounds
good doesn't it pick it out any color
you name it it'll be tied up with a bowl
and I'll be at your house tomorrow and
you say well what's the catch and the
catch is that it's the only car you're
going to get in your lifetime now what
are you going to do knowing that that's
the only car you're ever going to have
and you love that car you're going to
take care of it
like you cannot believe now what I'd
like to suggest you're not going to get
only one car in your lifetime but you're
going to get one body and one mind and
that's all you're gonna get and that
body of mine feels terrific now but it
has to last you a lifetime
and habit number five the last one you
for very special bonus clip is treat
people nicely with John Paul DeJoria
when I worked for other companies some
of them not mentioning names were so bad
they would treat people the old way I'm
the boss here's what you're gonna do
because I'm the boss right or there were
times for example when maybe had a
dollar for lunch you can't get a lot for
a dollar so I just knew that that's how
I was and if I had a company that I had
a control of my gosh everyone's gonna be
treated the way I wanted to be treated
so the minute we could afford it
everyone had free lunch whether you had
money or not you have free lunch we pay
for it for you
car pool will pay for that so we started
doing things for people that I wish
happened to me maybe that's part of fate
maybe because a lot of things along the
way weren't so good that as things
started getting good it was so easy for
me to share with our people so easy to
do that people sometimes don't save
money as soon as we possibly could
afford it we started profit sharing
where at the end of every year and we'll
take that profit sharing and put in a
retirement fund for you it's yours
it's yours if your so many years it goes
with you no matter where you go but
your buddy that's really incredible and
how much do you think that that sort of
Golden Rule approach has fed into your
ridiculously low turnover rate which is
literally almost unprecedented I mean
that's crazy I try and treat people
exactly the way they'd want to be
treated exactly the way I would have
wanted to be treated
I'm happy with my people I realized my
people aren't the company if my people
go my god the company goes people are
your company and they take care of the
customer the customer is always right no
matter what so what do we do so the
customers happier if somebody's unhappy
would try and discover why and because
you treat people this way and we'd love
them you walk in our company it's love
if you go through the front desk here in
Century City this girl just has the
biggest smile say hi welcome to John
Paul Mitchell Systems she loves what she
does our big problem is we don't have
turnover we have so many people out of
work for us and the thing is you gotta
wait for somebody to die now as we drill
we'll add one or two on obviously at a
time sure and we're pretty big now
because we're in 96 countries it's how
you take care of people anywhere in the
world you don't boss them around you
include them on what you're doing now I
have a bonus clip with Sara Blakely on
how to ask questions that I think you're
really gonna enjoy but before that is
that with a three-point landing question
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question for
one
what's one bold bed that you need to
commit to this week number two how can
you put reading into your daily habits
and number three pick three people who
you can treat nicely today and if you
like this video and will take action
after watching that give me a hashtag
believe down the comments below many
aspiring entrepreneurs even in this room
struggle to find their initial idea how
do you constantly find ways to invent
new products and where does your
inspiration come from you know I I mean
I think of a lot of ideas of traffic
lights I think of them all the time in
different places and I think it's part
of just being hyper observant I I like
to find white space I pay attention to
what are things that haven't evolved and
why
you know like there's certain things in
our society that updates itself and
changes and you know constantly and then
there's certain things that it's not and
so I'll ask myself questions all day
every day it's just the way my brain
works like I could even be looking at a
table and be like why is the table like
that
when was the table first created is that
the actual best design for a table or
could there be something different and
you know what Spanx went into men's and
that was randomly how that happened was
because I got curious that the man's
undershirt was created in 1918 and no
one had paid any attention to it since
it was literally the same thing and so I
just you know talked to my brother and
my husband about it and their
undershirts that the neck stretched out
or they were boxy and bulky under
clothes and I thought oh I'm just gonna
add a little bit of like or to the
cotton undershirt for men and so the
neck won't stretch out I'm gonna taper
it in at the waist so ideas come to me
like that ideas really up clearly I love
I have my assistant who's my right hand
lisa is she's been my right hand for 16
years can attest to this but I have 99
pages I don't know why it's 99 but she
told me the other day it's ninety nine
pages single-spaced types of ideas one
more idea so I II I think of ideas
constantly on airplanes in car you know
talking to somebody and I email it to
myself and then I just keep them and
logged them
if you want to know the three amazing
habits that the 1% use check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
there is one habit that I have adopted
in the last three years that has
fundamentally changed me as a business
person